hey guys how's it going welcome to ij
likes
i never know what to say after i welcome
you to
a video
welcome back to igc
i really just need to do a video of all
of the bloopers of
god i can't even talk hello friends
let's turn this brightness down
so i spent most of the last week in new
york if you want to watch that vlog um
here it is it's great it's fantastic
it's on my second channel but if you
don't want to watch that vlog let's just
continue on to the ij likes show and we
will start by
uh talking about some of the videos that
i liked this past week
so see this video all over the internet
so i couldn't help but show you guys
this otter jumps into these people's car
and it will not
come on
that you get
there's nothing for you in there
it's like bro hi
what you want we ain't got no snacks for
you otters are kind of cute i don't know
do you guys think otters are cute
how cute
okay oops this next video is this guy
who goes to a carnival game and tries to
win an xbox but guess what all he is
left with well no money because he spent
his entire life savings twenty six
hundred dollars on this carnival game
all he has to show for it is this
stuffed banana with dreadlocks
it's not possible that it wasn't rigged
gribaum says he kept trying to win back
his money by going double or nothing oh
you probably don't want any life advice
for me but if you're ever trying to win
a prize and you've already spent three
four five x the amount of money it would
have been to just go and buy it in the
first place that's a bad deal my friend
the app i've been most obsessed with
lately is timehop i don't think i've
mentioned it on here before it's an
application that will allow you to sync
up your twitter your flickr your
facebook your foursquare all of these
social networks and every day it'll take
you back in your history of social
networking time and show you what you
were doing in that day a couple years
ago next
is
oh no i can't find it so i was gonna
show you the ollo clip which is a wide
angle a fisheye and a macro lens for
your iphone now i had one for my old
iphone but the new iphone 5 one is out i
don't know i actually went shoot my
memory card was full okay um where'd i
leave off again so the auto clip will
clip it onto your phone and it
completely transforms your camera into a
wide angle fisheye macro lens it's
pretty magical so hopefully i find it
and i can insert some footage of me
showing it to you
ah what am i going to show you guys
today
let me find something
last week i was shooting a segment for
my new show hardwired which will be on
aol and i'm so excited to show it to you
no episodes are up yet but i met this
guy gary cass for one of the episodes
who created this wine dress i don't tell
you more about it because you have to
watch the episode he gave me a sample of
these jeans they're called isco the
denim language i don't ever really wear
normal jeans so i was so excited because
these ones
are you guys are not going to believe
this but i just filled up another sd
card
where'd i leave uh i don't even know
i was talking about gene i believe
they're a turkish company
right there and they're awesome because
i love unique denim they're fabulous
they're fabulous what i love most about
these is they're stretchy cause she got
a big buddha so i caught a big booty
cause i got a big booty so that called
me big booty it's true though i always
have to buy my jeans like two sizes
bigger because why she got a big booty
so i caught a big booty so i know
everyone probably has
one of the naked palettes this is the
naked 2 but that's not what i want to
show you i want to show you the naked
flushed and the naked decay basics
because when i'm traveling i don't want
to carry this big freaking thing and
this is perfect because the flushed has
a little bronzer a little highlighter
and some blush and the basics has just
all the basic colors you got your black
so your face naked too
so pretty and your little just wearing
your little hats and stuff and just
looking so nice anyway that's all i have
for you guys this week i'll be in san
francisco next week so
maybe i'll find you something cool there
for next week i can't believe i went
through three memory cards trying to do
this video and now my camera's doing
something crazy what are you doing to me
now i'm hearing beeping sounds make sure
you like subscribe i'll see you guys in
the next video i gotta go take care of
this beeping sound
you